Well, now it almost feels like a distant memory. But there was a moment this past fall when Hurricane Sandy hit the East Coast during the hottest year on record with a drought that covered two-thirds of the country, and wildfires, and floods. Lots of people seemed to be saying, all right, global warming. This is it, right? Not far away, at the polar ice caps, but right here at home. It's finally shown up.
现在回想起来，这似乎已成为遥远的记忆。但去年秋天有一个瞬间，飓风“桑迪”袭击了东海岸，而那一年是有记录以来最热的一年，全美三分之二的地区遭受干旱，山火与洪水频发。很多人似乎都在说，好吧，这就是全球变暖。就是这样，对吧？不是在远方的极地冰盖，而是在我们家门口。它终于出现了。
Simply put, when you look at Hurricane Sandy, do you see climate change, man-made climate change--
简单来说，当你看飓风“桑迪”时，你看到的是气候变化，人为的气候变化吗？
On TV, guys like Chris Matthews were asking the question, while over at CBS This Morning , a scientist named Michio Kaku was saying, sure, he once doubted that global warming was real.
在电视上，像克里斯·马修斯（Chris Matthews）这样的人在问这个问题，而在哥伦比亚广播公司的《今晨》节目中，一位名叫加来道雄（Michio Kaku）的科学家表示，当然，他曾经怀疑过全球变暖是否真实存在。
But then you look at the indicators, the fact that all the glaciers are receding. We have 100-year storms that are now the, quote, "new norm." We could be seeing a new way of life.
但当你观察这些指标，看到冰川都在消融的事实。我们经历的“百年一遇”的风暴现在成了所谓的“新常态”。我们可能正在目睹一种新的生活方式。
And of course, it's been amazing to see, since then, public opinion went through a massive turn. Broad, comprehensive legislation was passed to deal with climate change. Oh, right. That didn't happen.
当然，令人惊讶的是，从那时起，公众舆论发生了巨大的转变。一项处理气候变化的广泛、全面的立法得以通过。哦，对了。那根本没发生。
Because the conversation about climate change is stuck. It's stuck. It's stuck in the same utterly tiresome place that it has been stuck for years. There are the people who believe that global warming is happening, and there are the people who don't believe that, going back and forth with the same retread arguments over and over. According to a recent Gallup poll, just over half the country thinks that climate change is real and is man-made-- which, despite the crazy weather last year, is more or less exactly where it's been for most of the last decade, give or take a couple percentage points.
因为关于气候变化的讨论陷入了僵局。陷入了僵局。它陷入了多年来一直停滞不前的、极其令人厌烦的老地方。有一群人相信全球变暖正在发生，而另一群人不相信，双方反复兜售着同样的陈词滥调。根据最近的盖洛普民意调查，只有略多于半数的国民认为气候变化是真实的，且是由人为造成的——尽管去年的天气非常极端，但这与过去十年的大部分时间相比，差不多就是那个水平，上下波动仅几个百分点。
And today on our program, after a year that seemed like a dramatic preview of what climate scientists are predicting for all of our futures, we ask, why in the world is the conversation so stuck? That's going to be the first half of our show. And then in the second half of the show, we have found some places where it feels like battle lines are, in fact, shifting a little bit. We've found completely fascinating efforts by people who are consciously trying to lift us out of the mire and muck that we have been caught in, to end the standoff, to reinvent the exhausting, stupid climate change debate.
今天在我们的节目中，在经历了似乎是气候科学家为我们未来所预测的戏剧性预演的一年后，我们想问，为什么全世界的对话如此停滞？这将是节目的上半部分。在节目的后半部分，我们发现了一些战线实际上正在发生一点点转移的地方。我们发现了一些完全引人入胜的尝试，人们正在自觉地努力将我们从陷入的泥潭中拉出来，结束这种僵局，重新定义那场令人筋疲力尽、愚蠢的气候变化辩论。
In short, we have tried to assemble an hour on climate change that is not stuff that we have all heard before. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Please stay with us.
简而言之，我们试图策划一个关于气候变化的一小时节目，内容并不是我们都听过的老生常谈。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, "The CO2 in CO." You know, if you're looking for a place where people have been seeing extreme weather in their own backyards lately, Colorado is about as good as you're going to get. And we begin our program today with the story of a guy who is supposed to explain the climate there to the people who are most affected by the weather. That guy is the state climatologist, Nolan Doesken, and the story is about what a difficult job he had last year, for reasons that reporter Julia Kumari Drapkin will explain.
第一幕，“科罗拉多州的二氧化碳”。你知道，如果你想找一个最近在自家后院目睹极端天气的地方，科罗拉多州绝对是不二之选。今天节目的一开始，我们要讲述一个人的故事，他本应向受天气影响最严重的民众解释那里的气候状况。那个人是州气候学家诺兰·多斯肯（Nolan Doesken），这个故事关于他去年经历的一份困难工作，原因将由记者朱莉娅·库马里·德拉普金（Julia Kumari Drapkin）来解释。
Before I get to Nolan, a word about just how weird the weather was here last year. I moved to the state in April, and at first, the stuff I was hearing about was kind of subtle. One woman started noticing squirrel roadkill near her house, for example.
在我讲诺兰之前，先说说去年这里的天气有多怪。我四月份搬到这个州，起初，我听到的事情还挺隐晦的。比如，一位女士开始注意到她家附近的松鼠尸体。
Three roadkill squirrels. And I can't say that I've ever remember seeing a squirrel on our--
三只松鼠尸体。我不记得我以前见过松鼠在我们的……
The short winter meant squirrels were reproducing in greater numbers, spreading out to places they had never been before. Flowers bloomed weeks earlier than normal, way before farmers' markets even opened for the season. So people who sell flowers for a living had no place to sell.
短暂的冬天意味着松鼠的繁殖数量增加，扩散到了它们以前从未去过的地方。花朵比往常早开几周，甚至在农贸市场开市之前就开了。所以靠卖花为生的人根本没地方卖花。
That's because spring came early, throwing the entire agricultural growing season and pollination all out of whack. March, usually Colorado's snowiest month, had brought the lowest recorded snowfall in history. And in Colorado, snow equals water supply. By the end of May, things were starting to feel dire.
这是因为春天来得太早，导致整个农业种植季节和授粉过程乱套了。三月，通常是科罗拉多州降雪最多的月份，却迎来了有记录以来最低的降雪量。而在科罗拉多州，降雪就等于供水。到五月底，情况开始变得严峻起来。
[FRUSTRATED SCREAM]
[沮丧的尖叫]
That's rancher Marla Bear Bishop freaking out when she sees her stunted hayfield.
那是牧场主玛拉·贝尔·毕晓普（Marla Bear Bishop）在看到她那发育不良的干草地时抓狂的声音。
I know what I-- I know what looks right to me. It's not right. Nothing about this is right.
我知道我……我知道什么是正常的。这不对劲。这其中没有一点是正常的。
Her hayfield-- it's alfalfa-- is water-starved. The plants should be six inches taller than they are right now. If they don't grow, she's got no feed for her animals. Her neighbor Pat Polson had 80 head of cattle, but only enough hay for 20.
她的干草地——那是苜蓿——缺水严重。植物本应比现在高出六英寸。如果不生长，她的动物就没饲料吃。她的邻居帕特·波尔森（Pat Polson）有80头牛，但干草只够20头吃。
Meanwhile, bears were killing off livestock like crazy because they didn't have enough to eat in the woods. Because there weren't enough acorns. Because the oak leaves froze. Because they came out too early.
与此同时，熊在疯狂地捕杀牲畜，因为它们在树林里没有足够的食物吃。因为橡子不够多。因为橡树叶过早冻死了。因为它们出没得太早了。
Colorado Climate Center.
科罗拉多气候中心。
Hi, is this Nolan?
你好，是诺兰吗？
It is, with a carrot in his mouth.
是我，嘴里叼着胡萝卜。
Oh, that's OK.
哦，没关系。
So at the end of May, I called the guy this story's about, the state climatologist, Noland Doesken, to talk to him about all the weirdness. I got him at lunchtime. I asked him, what are you telling people? Are you telling them the extreme weather they're seeing is climate change?
所以五月底，我给这个故事的主人公——州气候学家诺兰·多斯肯打了电话，想和他聊聊所有这些怪事。我是在午餐时间联系上他的。我问他，你都在告诉人们什么？你是在告诉他们，他们所看到的极端天气就是气候变化吗？
And he said, no. Nolan believes in climate change, but he said there's no way to tell if any particular hot spell or drought happened because of it. And for almost every bizarre weather scenario happening now, he can find a year just like it. Take 1910. Warm spring, barely snowed in March.
他说，不。诺兰相信气候变化，但他表示，无法判断任何特定的热浪或干旱是否由此引起。对于现在发生的几乎每一个奇怪的天气情景，他都能找到相似的一年。拿1910年来说。温暖的春天，三月几乎没下雪。
So about the time you think, wow, this is unprecedented. We've never had anything like this-- lo and behold, we have had something sort of like it, and it was fully 100 years ago. So what it does point out is that our climate is variable. Variability wins.
所以当你觉得，哇，这真是史无前例。我们从来没见过这样的事情——结果发现，我们确实遇到过类似的事情，而且整整100年前就发生过。所以这指出了我们的气候是多变的。多变性胜出。
Variability. That's the word climate scientists use when they mean it can get hotter, it can get colder-- it's normal. No reason to panic. Nolan said this in May.
多变性。这就是气候科学家在表示天气可能变热、可能变冷时使用的词——这是正常的。没必要恐慌。诺兰是在五月份这么说的。
By June, panic started to seem like a reasonable option. Temperature records kept breaking, not just in Colorado, but nationwide. Mosquitoes descended. The worst West Nile virus outbreak in the state hit the county where I live.
到了六月，恐慌开始看起来像是一个合理的选择。温度记录不断被打破，不仅是在科罗拉多州，全国范围皆是如此。蚊子肆虐。该州有史以来最严重的西尼罗河病毒爆发袭击了我居住的县。
The land turned brown. Everywhere you stepped felt crunchy, like the whole state was one big tinderbox. Everybody was praying for rain, but the first storms that came were practically rainless, just flashes of lightning like giant matches hovering over people's houses. It was terrifying.
土地变成了褐色。每走一步都感觉嘎吱作响，好像整个州就是一个巨大的火药桶。每个人都在祈祷下雨，但最初来临的风暴几乎没带来什么雨水，只是像巨大的火柴盘旋在人们房屋上空的闪电。这太可怕了。
And then the fires came and stayed. 2012 was the most destructive wildfire season in Colorado history, burning over 600 houses. Hugh Carson was fighting the fires from the air over Fort Collins, and later, in Idaho. He'd been doing this work for decades. But last summer's fires were different.
然后山火来了，并留了下来。2012年是科罗拉多州历史上最具破坏性的山火季节，烧毁了超过600栋房屋。休·卡森（Hugh Carson）曾在柯林斯堡上空以及后来的爱达荷州参与过灭火工作。他从事这项工作已经几十年了。但去年夏天的火灾不同寻常。
The first time I heard it described, I think, was about the 16th of June. And one of my air attacks down at Jefferson County Airport said, Carson, you would not believe what we're seeing out there. I said, what? He says, I saw a sheet of flame approximately half a mile long and 1,000 feet high, and all it was doing was sitting there and shimmering at me.
我第一次听到对此的描述，我想是在6月16日左右。我的一位在杰斐逊县机场的空中指挥官说，卡森，你不会相信我们在外面看到了什么。我说，什么？他说，我看到了一片大约半英里长、1000英尺高的火墙，它就待在那里，在我面前闪烁。
And he said it in exactly that tone. It was sitting there shimmering at me. And I queried other air attacks, and they said, yeah, we're seeing stuff out there like that weird stuff, that we've never seen before in the last 25 years, since this burn-down in the West started happening.
他就是用那种语气说的。它就在那里对我闪烁。我询问了其他空中指挥官，他们说，是的，我们在外面看到了那种奇怪的东西，这是过去25年来西部开始发生这种焚烧现象以来我们从未见过的。
Nobody could escape what was going on, including the state climatologist, Nolan Doesken. Every day the phone was ringing in his office, people asking him, is this climate change? Is this what the future is going to look like? And he gave them the answer he always has-- variability.
没有人能逃避正在发生的事情，包括州气候学家诺兰·多斯肯。每天他的办公室电话铃声不断，人们问他，这是气候变化吗？未来的日子会是这样吗？他给出了他一直以来的回答——多变性。
But the summer changed him. Just a week after we had first spoken, Nolan left for a vacation with his wife to Michigan, and that's when the biggest of the wildfires broke out, a few miles from his house in Fort Collins.
但那个夏天改变了他。就在我们第一次交谈的一周后，诺兰和妻子去密歇根度假，就在那时，最大的山火爆发了，距离他在柯林斯堡的家只有几英里。
And then we drove home into the heat and into the smoke. 400 yards from our office, we went past a National Guard checkpoint every day. Helicopters flying, smoke plumes. Having close friends whose homes burned or who were evacuated for many weeks, it's just-- it hits you so hard.
然后我们开车回家，进入了酷热和烟雾中。距离我们办公室400码的地方，我们每天都要经过国民警卫队的检查站。直升机在飞，烟雾缭绕。有亲密朋友的房子被烧毁或被迫撤离数周，这真的……这让你感到非常沉重。
Most upsetting was what happened to his neighbor's daughter from the nearby dairy farm. The fires had died down some, but the river near their farm still had tons of ash in it.
最令人难过的是他邻居的女儿，来自附近的奶牛场。火势有所减弱，但他们农场附近的河里仍然有大量的灰烬。
Probably because of the pump clogging, probably because of the ash from the wildfire in the irrigation system, the young girl was electrocuted. That was about as painful as anything about the whole summer season, just knowing their precious daughter was lost to a situation beyond their control.
可能是因为泵堵塞了，可能是因为灌溉系统里有山火的灰烬，那个年轻女孩触电身亡了。这是整个夏季最让人痛苦的事情，只是知道他们珍贵的女儿因一个他们无法控制的情况而失去。
His neighbor's death was one of the things that made him start to think differently about the data. The important question wasn't, is this particular drought caused by climate change? Whether it was or wasn't didn't matter. Because either way, he realized, if the climate models are right, he was seeing the future. Seeing were Colorado was headed-- droughts and dead crops and fires-- and it was horrible.
邻居的去世是让他开始对数据产生不同想法的原因之一。重要的问题不是，这次特定的干旱是否由气候变化引起？它是否引起并不重要。因为他意识到，无论如何，如果气候模型是正确的，他正在目睹未来。看到了科罗拉多州未来的走向——干旱、庄稼枯死和火灾——这太可怕了。
You just sort of used to be able to say, ah, that's just a computer model. And then you get to see, and this is what those numeric outputs from that model feel like. Say, ooh, I don't want to have to live through year after year after year of this. This will be a different place if that is what our climate will be like.
你过去只是习惯于说，啊，那只是一个计算机模型。然后你亲眼所见，这就是那些模型输出的数值所带来的真实感受。你会说，喔，我不想年复一年地经历这种生活。如果我们的气候就是这样，那这将是一个完全不同的地方。
Nolan's the person Colorado farmers and ranchers turn to, the one they trust to tell them what the weather has done, what it is doing, and what it will do. That's been his job for 36 years. Now that he was seeing cause for alarm, would he tell people that?
诺兰是科罗拉多州农民和牧场主求助的对象，他们信任他，让他告诉他们天气发生了什么，正在发生什么，以及未来会发生什么。这是他36年来的工作。现在他看到了警示的理由，他会告诉人们吗？
In reporting on climate change, I found that scientists don't always level with people that way. I've interviewed three different scientists who are already preparing for the worst. They've bought second homes high above sea level. They'll confess stuff like this to me in private, but never to the public.
在报道气候变化时，我发现科学家并不总是那样坦诚地对待人们。我采访了三位不同的科学家，他们已经在为最坏的情况做准备了。他们买了远离海平面的第二套房。他们会私下向我坦白这些，但绝不会向公众透露。
And sure, it's not scientific information, but it's telling. Saying emphatically, this is what the climate models predict for your land and your livelihood-- that's information people would probably take seriously as they decide their own long-term plans. So would Nolan start telling people, I believe 2012 is a sign of where Colorado is headed with climate change, and we're in trouble?
当然，这不是科学信息，但这很有说明意义。明确地指出，这就是气候模型为你所处的土地和生计所作出的预测——这很可能是人们在决定自己的长期计划时会认真对待的信息。那么，诺兰会开始告诉人们，我相信2012年是科罗拉多州气候变化走向的一个迹象，我们有麻烦了吗？
In September, I asked him to come to Paonia, in Western Colorado, where I'd been reporting, to meet with a few of the people I'd met who'd had trouble last year. One of the sheep ranchers, Brian Farmer, invited us up to his place.
九月，我请他去我一直在报道的科罗拉多州西部的佩奥尼亚（Paonia），去见我遇到的几个去年过得不太好的人。其中一位羊农布莱恩·法默（Brian Farmer）邀请我们去他家。
Howdy.
你好。
Hello there.
Brian.
布莱恩。
Brian, I'm Nolan Doesken.
布莱恩，我是诺兰·多斯肯。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Have we met before?
我们以前见过吗？
Brian comes from a pretty conservative family, one of the first to settle here in 1890. He's got one of the bigger operations in town-- 300 cows and up to 8,000 sheep. This year Brian had a terrible time finding pasture for them all.
布莱恩来自一个相当保守的家庭，是1890年第一批在这里定居的人之一。他是镇上规模较大的经营者之一——有300头牛和多达8000只羊。今年布莱恩为它们找牧场费尽了周折。
Without irrigation water, Brian's ranch reverts to the desert it actually is. Brian and Nolan begin talking about all this, speaking a dialect that I like to call Almanac. Anyone who's been here long enough can do this. They rattle off the hot years, the wet years, the bumper crop years.
没有灌溉水，布莱恩的牧场就变回了它本来就是的沙漠。布莱恩和诺兰开始讨论这一切，说着一种我称之为“年鉴”的方言。任何在这里待得足够久的人都能做到这一点。他们如数家珍地列举着炎热的年份、湿润的年份、丰收的年份。
And then it didn't dry up for another 17 to 20 years. And then it dried up for another three years in a row.
然后它又有17到20年没有干涸。然后它又连续三年干涸了。
And then the '80s and '90s were all really darn good years.
然后80年代和90年代都是非常棒的年份。
Pretty good. I was--
相当不错。我当时……
Until the late '80s.
直到80年代末。
I kept waiting for Nolan to lay it out for Brian, to tell Brian that climate change is either here or on the way, and that this year, 2012, is what it's going to be like in the near future. But this is what Nolan said.
我一直等着诺兰向布莱恩摊牌，告诉布莱恩气候变化要么已经到来，要么正在路上，而且今年，即2012年，就是不久后的常态。但诺兰是这样说的。
The year that we just experienced that was way unusual to us now, they're saying may be the norm 30 to 40 years from now. And I wrestle with that and say, well, I don't know.
我们刚刚经历的这一年对我们来说非常反常，他们说这可能是三四十年后的常态。我为此纠结，我说，嗯，我不知道。
"I don't know"? Finally, I raised the subject with Brian.
“我不知道”？最后，我向布莱恩提出了这个话题。
Do you believe in climate change at this stage of the game?
在这个阶段，你相信气候变化吗？
No, not enough to affect us. And secondly, there's nothing we can do about it, or I can do about it myself, personally.
不，没有到影响我们的程度。其次，我们对此无能为力，或者我自己个人也无能为力。
Here's what Nolan says when he hears that-- nothing. Back in the car, Nolan shrugged.
当听到这话时，诺兰的反应是——什么也没说。回到车里，诺兰耸了耸肩。
I'm not that surprised that he wasn't that aware or concerned about temperature changes.
他不太了解或不关心温度变化，我并不感到惊讶。
Should he be?
他应该吗？
Probably.
大概吧。
Why didn't you tell him to worry?
你为什么不告诉他要担心？
Because I have found that there's no-- you know, telling people to believe something different than what they do hardly ever has an impact. And if anything, it just is a reason for alienation. For me to just to make a bold statement, that's not going to serve any good purpose.
因为我发现根本没有……你知道，告诉人们去相信与他们观点不同的东西几乎从不会产生影响。如果有的话，它只会成为疏远的理由。对于我来说，仅仅发表一个大胆的声明，那不会起到任何好的作用。
Which makes a lot of sense. The fact is the people most directly affected by climate change around the state are also the most likely not to believe it's real. And they say all the reasons you've probably heard.
这很有道理。事实是，该州受气候变化直接影响最深的人，也最有可能不相信它是真实的。他们会说出你可能听过的所有理由。
It's a liberal conspiracy. Or God's in charge. Or the science is wrong, or rigged, or inconclusive. Even the word "environmentalist" can trigger outrage, like when this rancher, Larry Moore, charged at me with his four-wheeler.
这是自由派的阴谋。或者上帝在掌管一切。或者科学是错误的、被操纵的或结论未定的。甚至“环保主义者”这个词都能引发愤怒，就像那个牧场主拉里·摩尔（Larry Moore）开着四轮驱动车向我冲过来时那样。
You know, I'm kind of pissed off. You didn't tell me who you were, who you represented. That you were one of these environmentalists that are giving us so much [BLEEP] out there.
你知道，我有点火大。你没告诉我你是谁，你代表谁。你竟然是给我们带来这么多[哔——]的环保主义者之一。
Wait, I'm sorry--
等等，我很抱歉……
I oughta take that damned recorder and smash it to smithereens.
我应该把那个该死的录音机砸得粉碎。
Wha-- oh-- oh, I'm just-- I'm  reporting for KVNF. But why are you so upset-- I'm sorry. I didn't mean to--
什么……哦……哦，我只是……我在为KVNF做报道。但你为什么这么生气——对不起。我不是故意的……
Shut that thing off.
把那东西关掉。
Oh, I'm s---
哦，我很抱……
He felt bad about losing his cool. Invited me up for cookies and coffee after. But you can understand why any message about climate change is the last thing a lot of farmers and ranchers want to hear. They stand to lose so much if climate models come true.
他对失态感到抱歉。后来还邀请我去吃饼干和喝咖啡。但你可以理解为什么任何关于气候变化的信息都是许多农民和牧场主最不想听到的。如果气候模型成为现实，他们将损失惨重。
Water is simply worth more, in Colorado, servicing a condo than it is irrigating an alfalfa field. If water's scarce, agriculture will shrink. Water will be diverted to cities and suburbs, which are growing in the state. Nolan and I talked about this for a while in the car, back at Brian's ranch. Finally, Nolan told me he was thinking about being more frank with his constituents.
在科罗拉多州，水供应公寓的价值简直比灌溉苜蓿地更高。如果水资源短缺，农业就会萎缩。水将被引向该州不断增长的城市和郊区。诺兰和我在车里讨论了一会儿这个问题，当时在布莱恩的牧场。最后，诺兰告诉我，他正在考虑对他的选民更坦诚一些。
At the Colorado Farm Show in 2013, I will tell the farmers that I-- my level of concern, based on my personal experience with the hot summer, will change the way I communicate the problem.
在2013年的科罗拉多农展会上，我会告诉农民们，我……基于我对炎热夏天的个人经验，我的担忧程度会改变我沟通这个问题的方式。
So you're going to tell a group of farmers in 2013?
所以你打算在2013年告诉一群农民？
I didn't say that, but I might. It all-- I don't script what comes out of my mouth.
我没那么说，但我可能会。这完全……我不会写下我要说的话。
I'll be there. When is it?
我会去的。什么时候？
Late January, in Greeley, Colorado.
一月下旬，在科罗拉多州的格里利（Greeley）。
I'll be there. With my mic.
我会去的。带着我的麦克风。
With your mic.
带着你的麦克风。
Every year at the end of January, Nolan delivers the weather report at the Colorado Farm Show. It's like the State of the Union address for farmers and ranchers. Hundreds of them come, some of them just to listen to him.
每年一月底，诺兰都会在科罗拉多农展会上发表天气报告。这对农民和牧场主来说就像是国情咨文。成百上千人会来，有些人就是为了听他讲。
Nolan has been giving this talk for 12 years, and in all those years, he's never once brought up climate change. Not once. But every time, the first or second question he gets asked in the Q & A is, what do you think about climate change? And every time, there's been a local reporter in the front row with a notebook.
诺兰讲这个已经12年了，在这些年里，他从来没提过气候变化。一次都没有。但每次在问答环节，他被问到的第一个或第二个问题总是，你对气候变化怎么看？而且每次，前排都有一个带着笔记本的地方记者。
And he would immediately begin taking notes the minute I started to speak. And I always found that a little bit intimidating. And the audience, the vast majority, were climate change skeptics, and they sort of wanted me to embarrass myself in front of them and the newspaper reporter.
他会在我开口的瞬间立即开始做笔记。我一直觉得这有点令人生畏。而听众中的绝大多数都是气候变化怀疑论者，他们有点希望我在他们和报社记者面前出丑。
Taking a stand can be dangerous. In recent years, climatologists in four states have lost their positions because of what they said publicly about climate change-- Oregon, Virginia, Delaware, Georgia. Democratic governors got rid of climatologists who didn't embrace climate change, and a Republican fired two who did.
表明立场可能会很危险。近年来，在四个州，气候学家因为公开谈论气候变化而丢了工作——俄勒冈州、弗吉尼亚州、特拉华州、佐治亚州。民主党州长赶走了不拥护气候变化的气候学家，而共和党州长解雇了两个拥护气候学家的。
We think there'll be a few more chairs delivered in a minute or two.
我们认为再过一两分钟会有几把椅子送进来。
Nolan's talk is in a side room. It's packed. They bring more chairs in, but it's still standing room only by the time he starts. There are about 200 people from Colorado, and also some from other drought-stricken states-- Wyoming, Nebraska, Oklahoma.
诺兰的讲座在一个侧厅。挤满了人。他们又搬来了一些椅子，但当他开始讲时，还是站满了人。大约有200人来自科罗拉多州，也有一些来自其他干旱受灾州——怀俄明州、内布拉斯加州、俄克拉荷马州。
Nolan's talk is a PowerPoint. He starts with data from 1890.
诺兰的讲座用的是PowerPoint。他从1890年的数据开始讲起。
Then we had the drought for years of the 1900s into the late 1920s. The Dust Bowl, the '30s--
然后我们经历了1900年代到1920年代末的多年干旱。尘暴，30年代……
And that was just the beginning. He showed 187 slides. 187 slides. 30 minutes, 45 minutes, an hour-- it was so long, there was an intermission.
那仅仅是个开始。他展示了187张幻灯片。187张幻灯片。30分钟，45分钟，一小时……时间太长了，中间还休息了一次。
There may be some donuts left. There might be some coffee left. Stretch.
可能还剩些甜甜圈。可能还剩些咖啡。伸展一下。
After the break, he's still going full steam. Soon, we're an hour and 40 minutes in, and no mention of climate change. 20 more minutes pass. And then, right at the end.
休息过后，他依然火力全开。很快，我们已经过去了一小时40分钟，依然没提到气候变化。又过了20分钟。然后，就在最后。
OK. I have one minute left.
好了。我还有一分钟。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
One minute left to tell you a story.
还有一分钟讲个故事。
He shows a slide that says, "Do I have time for a little story?" That's all it says.
他展示了一张幻灯片，上面写着：“我有时间讲个小故事吗？”仅此而已。
And that is a story of a climatologist grappling with the question that all of you wanted to ask me today, and some of you have asked me every year. When I finish my talk, you'll end up saying, well, tell me about climate change. What do you think? Or some of you have told me exactly what you think.
这就是一个气候学家在努力解决你们今天都想问我的问题，有些人每年都问我。当我讲完话，你们最后会说，好吧，跟我讲讲气候变化吧。你怎么看？或者你们中的一些人已经告诉了我你们是怎么想的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And here's where Nolan tells them. Scientists are not 100% certain, but they are, he says, pretty darn confident that the globe is warming, and that's it's our fault.
这就是诺兰告诉他们的地方。科学家们虽然并非100%确定，但他说，他们非常有把握全球正在变暖，而且这是我们的错。
2012 told me something that I hadn't been able to come to grips with that well until 2012 came along. The temperatures we experienced this year, which were pretty extreme, yeah, they happened before. 1934, it happened before. So natural variations can cause it.
2012年告诉了我一些我在2012年来临之前无法很好理解的事情。我们今年经历的气温，确实很极端，是的，这种情况以前发生过。1934年，以前发生过。所以自然变化可以引起它。
But if the computer models are anything close to right-- and I'm not a computer modeler. You can't shoot at me. But if those models are anywhere close to right, 2012 will be an average year in just a few decades.
但是，如果计算机模型接近事实——我不是计算机建模专家。你们不能对我开火。但如果这些模型接近事实，那么2012年的天气在几十年后将成为常态。
So that was it. Kind of soft, but he said it. And then he got nervous, changed the subject, toggled back a few slides, and started talking about flooding.
所以就是这样。语气有点柔和，但他说了。然后他变得紧张，换了话题，翻回几张幻灯片，开始谈论洪水。
Flooding.
洪水。
And then it was over.
然后就结束了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I wondered if people even got what he was saying. So I asked around in the crowd afterwards. I met Dave Sharman, who raises cattle.
我不知道人们是否理解了他所说的。所以事后我在人群中询问了一下。我遇到了养牛的戴夫·夏尔曼（Dave Sharman）。
What about that last story that he just told?
关于他刚才讲的最后一个故事怎么样？
What was it on? Oh, on floods?
讲的是什么？哦，关于洪水吗？
The one where he talks about climate change.
他谈论气候变化的那一个。
On the flood parts, you mean?
你是说洪水部分吗？
Well, yeah, and his little story about climate change. You don't remember that part?
嗯，是的，还有他关于气候变化的小故事。你不记得那部分了吗？
No. I sure don't. I know he talked about something there, but I don't remember the specifics.
不。我确实不记得。我知道他讲了一些东西，但我记不清具体细节了。
As for the newspaper reporter Nolan always worried about, from Greeley Tribune , he left before the end. He had a basketball game to go to. So he missed his scoop. Nolan's big warning wasn't even on the record.
至于诺兰一直担心的那个《格里利论坛报》的报社记者，他在结束前就走了。他要去看篮球比赛。所以他错过了独家新闻。诺兰的重要警告甚至没有被记录下来。
Does that give you a sense of relief?
这让你感到释怀吗？
Yeah, this time around, I would say disappointment. Because in the past, I dreaded the story being written about, Doesken speaking about climate change. And I don't dread that anymore. That's a change. And when I said that, there was a lot of nodding of heads, more than ever. It was amazing to see.
是的，这一次，我会说感到失望。因为在过去，我害怕写关于多斯肯谈论气候变化的新闻。而我现在不再害怕了。这是一个改变。当我那样说时，有很多人点头，比以往任何时候都多。看到这一幕真是太神奇了。
Measured against the damages from the weather last year, billions of dollars of lost property in revenue nationwide, and measured against the massive changes climate models predict for the coming decades in Colorado, what the state's top climate official took was a tiny step. But at least it was a first step.
对比去年天气造成的损失，全国数十亿美元的财产和收入损失，再对比气候模型对科罗拉多州未来几十年预测的巨大变化，该州最高气候官员迈出了一小步。但至少这是第一步。
Nolan spent so many years being afraid, feeling like a conversation about all this was impossible. But 2012 made it possible. And now he feels like it's OK. It's time to talk about it.
诺兰花了很多年感到害怕，觉得关于这一切的对话是不可能的。但2012年让这一切成为可能。现在他觉得没关系了。是时候谈论它了。
Julia Kumari Drapkin. Her climate reporting project at Colorado's KVNF is called iSeeChange. The website-- thealmanac.org. Coming up, secret things that Republicans on Capitol Hill say to each other about climate change, but only when microphones are off. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
朱莉娅·库马里·德拉普金。她在科罗拉多KVNF电台的气候报道项目叫“iSeeChange”。网址——thealmanac.org。接下来，国会山的共和党人在麦克风关闭时，私下里谈论的关于气候变化的秘密。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Hot in My Backyard," our premise today is we have started to see in our daily lives around this country the kind of extreme weather that scientists say that we are in store for as the world heats up. I'm talking hurricanes, droughts, floods, some of the hottest years on record, one after another.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，“我家后院很热”，我们今天的前提是，我们已经开始在全国各地的日常生活中看到气候学家所说的随着世界变暖我们将会遭遇的极端天气。我说的是飓风、干旱、洪水，有记录以来一个接一个最热的年份。
But the politics of climate change, the way that we talk about it in this country, has been stuck for years. Both Republicans and Democrats have been mired in their own ways of looking at the issue. In this half of today's program, we have a pair of stories-- one looking at somebody on the left, the other somebody on the right, who are trying to reinvent the politics on their side of the aisle.
但是气候变化的政治，也就是我们在国内讨论它的方式，多年来一直停滞不前。共和党人和民主党人都陷入了他们自己看待这个问题的模式中。在今天节目的这一半，我们有两个故事——一个关注左翼，另一个关注右翼，他们都在试图重塑各自党派的政治观点。
And what we're going to do is we're going to start with the Republicans with Act Two, which we are calling "Right Man For the Job." And environmental lobbyists told me last week that our country will never do anything about global warming as long as climate denial is such a big part of Republican Party dogma, right? Until that changes, he said, you can't get the votes to pass anything.
我们要从共和党人开始，进入第二幕，我们称之为“合适的人选”。环境说客上周告诉我，只要气候否定论还是共和党信条的重要组成部分，我们国家就永远不会对全球变暖采取任何行动，对吧？他说，在那改变之前，你是无法获得通过任何法案所需的选票的。
But there is a man out there whose mission is to make it possible for Republican candidates to say global warming is real. To make climate change safe for Republicans. And that man is a Republican. Ben Calhoun has the story.
但有一个人，他的使命是让共和党候选人能够说全球变暖是真实存在的。让气候变化对共和党人来说变得安全。而那个人是一位共和党人。本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）带来了这个故事。
Bob Inglis spent a total of 12 years as a Republican congressman in South Carolina. And here's how conservative he was. These are the numbers. Christian Coalition, 100% lifetime rating. National Right to Life, 100%. American Conservative Union, 93. An A with the NRA.
鲍勃·英格利斯（Bob Inglis）在南卡罗来纳州担任了总共12年的共和党国会议员。这就是他有多保守。这些是数字。基督教联盟（Christian Coalition）给出的终身评分为100%。全国生命权委员会（National Right to Life）100%。美国保守联盟（American Conservative Union）93%。美国全国步枪协会（NRA）给出的A级。
What are some of the things that you've been called since you've been pursuing the climate change issue?
自从你开始关注气候变化问题以来，你被称为的一些东西是什么？
Unpredictable, unreliable, unfaithful. A heretic, you know. I've been called the Al Gore of the Republican Party. And that was not meant as a compliment. [LAUGHTER]
不可预测、不可靠、不忠诚。异教徒，你知道的。我被称为共和党内的阿尔·戈尔（Al Gore）。那并不是什么赞美。[笑声]
I mean, of any of the things that you've been called, are there any that have really gotten under your skin at all, or been particularly frustrating?
我是说，在你被叫过的所有称呼中，有没有哪个真的让你感到难受，或者特别让你沮丧？
I think when I was called a traitor on the internet by one of my son's friends, who grew up with him. That-- that hurt. .
我想是当我被我儿子的一位朋友在互联网上称为叛徒时，他是我儿子一起长大的朋友。那……那确实很伤人。
Bob Inglis got taken down in the Tea Party wave of 2010. And he's now talked about as this textbook cautionary tale for Republicans about how dangerous climate change is for conservatives. Going into the election, Inglis had taken a few votes that annoyed staunch conservatives-- voting for the bank bailout, against the troop surge. And Inglis says, sure, those votes hurt him. But, he says, climate change was what did him in.
鲍勃·英格利斯在2010年的茶党浪潮中下台了。他现在被视为共和党人的反面教材，关于气候变化对保守派有多危险。在选举前，英格利斯投了几张让坚定的保守派感到恼火的票——投票支持银行救助，反对增兵。英格利斯说，当然，那些投票伤害了他。但他说，气候变化才是让他下台的原因。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
For instance, at a debate during the Republican primary, Bob's on stage with four Republican challengers. One by one, they say climate change hasn't been proven, or that it doesn't exist. They mock Inglis about climate change.
例如，在共和党初选期间的一场辩论中，鲍勃和四位共和党挑战者同台。他们一个接一个地说气候变化未经证实，或者它根本不存在。他们嘲笑英格利斯关于气候变化的话题。
At one point, a South Carolina state senator named David Thomas stands up. Thomas had actually supported Inglis in previous elections. But now he was running against him, trying to take his seat.
有一次，一位名叫大卫·托马斯（David Thomas）的南卡罗来纳州州参议员站了起来。托马斯实际上在之前的选举中支持过英格利斯。但现在他正在和他竞争，试图夺取他的席位。
Bob has gone astray. And I love Bob, but his insistence on the idea of catastrophic man-made global warming has taken him down a wrong path.
鲍勃误入歧途了。我爱鲍勃，但他坚持认为人为导致的灾难性全球变暖，让他走上了一条错误的道路。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Bob Inglis's eventual defeat was humiliating. He ultimately lost to a Tea Party-backed challenger, 71% to 29. I just want to say those numbers again. Bob Inglis, in a district he won six times, lost 71% to 29.
鲍勃·英格利斯的最终失败是屈辱的。他最终以71%对29%的比例输给了茶党支持的挑战者。我只想再说一遍这些数字。鲍勃·英格利斯，在他赢过六次的选区，以71%对29%输掉了。
After that, Bob spent some time thinking about what to do next, and decided what he'd do would be to devote himself to the very issue that got him unelected. Double down on climate change. So he started a nonprofit called the Energy and Enterprise Initiative.
在那之后，鲍勃花了一些时间思考下一步该做什么，决定他要做的事就是投身于让他落选的那个问题。在气候变化问题上加倍投入。所以他创办了一个名为“能源与企业倡议”（Energy and Enterprise Initiative）的非营利组织。
And now he spends his time making the case for climate change in front of the most conservative audiences in the country, trying to build a conservative coalition on the issue. Trying to remove some of the political stigma that the issue has with people on the Right. I know. Could not be easier.
现在他花时间在全国最保守的听众面前为气候变化辩护，试图在该问题上建立一个保守派联盟。试图消除这个问题在右翼人士心中所具有的一些政治污名。我知道。谈何容易。
Every fiber in my body's saying you're a conservative. You can't believe this.
我身体的每一个细胞都在说你是个保守派。你不能相信这个。
This is Super Talk Mississippi , the top conservative talk network in the state of Mississippi. This is the morning host, Paul Gallo, interviewing Bob. Just to be clear, this was the first question, right out of the gate.
这是“密西西比超级谈话”（Super Talk Mississippi），该州最大的保守派谈话网络。这是早间主持人保罗·加洛（Paul Gallo）在采访鲍勃。明确一下，这是开场后的第一个问题。
You're asking me, as a dyed-in-the-wool, native-born Mississippian, will die here, to believe that humans are responsible for global warming, and we must admit that. Mic's yours, sir.
你是在要求我，作为一个根深蒂固、土生土长的密西西比人，将死在这里的人，去相信人类应对全球变暖负责，而且我们必须承认这一点。麦克风给你了，先生。
Well, yeah. I think that it is. The challenge here, Paul, is it's a conversation started by liberals, right? We have liberals that basically started the conversation, and what we're used to as conservatives is they gin up hysteria, and then they drive through some regulations and some tax increases and grow government, right? And so it's natural that we respond with no, we don't want to do that. But what we're saying is, OK, what if we change this conversation?
嗯，是的。我认为是的。这里的挑战是，保罗，这是一个由自由派发起的对话，对吧？我们有自由派基本上发起了这个对话，而作为保守派，我们习惯的是他们煽动歇斯底里，然后强行通过一些法规和增税，让政府扩张，对吧？所以我们回应说，不，我们不想那样做，是很自然的。但我们说的是，好吧，如果我们改变这种对话呢？
Bob believes the conversation about climate change is broken. Partly because the Left and the Right are incapable of talking to each other about the issue. On the liberal side, he doesn't think liberals understand what they look like when they try to argue climate change to conservatives. How because the evidence is on their side, they often overplay their hand, and they come off scold-y and condescending.
鲍勃认为关于气候变化的对话已经破裂了。部分原因是因为左派和右派无法就这个问题进行交流。在自由派这边，他不认为自由派明白当他们试图向保守派论证气候变化时他们看起来像什么。因为证据在他们那边，他们经常把牌出得太满，表现得像个说教者，居高临下。
Bob also says he doesn't think liberals understand that conservatives see climate change as what he calls a, quote, "lifestyle issue." He says conservatives feel like their version of the American dream is under attack, that somehow, parents driving their kids through the suburbs in SUVs to soccer practice are being blamed as the cause of global warming, when in fact, everyone uses a lot of electricity and gasoline. Everybody flies on planes.
鲍勃还说，他不认为自由派明白保守派将气候变化视为他所说的“生活方式问题”。他说保守派觉得他们版本的“美国梦”受到了攻击，似乎开车送孩子去郊区练球的父母因为驾驶SUV而被指责为全球变暖的罪魁祸首，而实际上，每个人都在大量使用电力和汽油。每个人都在乘飞机。
Bob thinks he can win conservatives over more effectively by saying to them, I share your values. I know you're not a bad person. But I think we got this one wrong.
鲍勃认为，通过对他们说，我认同你们的价值观，我知道你们不是坏人，但我认为我们在这一点上错了，他能更有效地赢得保守派。
If you believe in taking care of this part of Eden that's left, and you believe in creation care--
如果你相信照顾好剩下的伊甸园部分，并且相信创造的关怀——
OK, in all due respect, the people of South Carolina apparently disagreed with you, as far as global warming.
好了，恕我直言，南卡罗来纳州的人民显然不同意你的观点，关于全球变暖。
That's right. At this point, they do.
没错。在这一点上，他们确实不同意。
I don't believe that humans are creating this. Because-- and neither do, apparently, a vast majority of climatologists out there.
我不相信人类正在制造这个。因为——显然，绝大多数气候学家也不相信。
No, I was tracking--
不，我是在追踪——
That humans--
人类——
I was tracking with you until that last part. You're just wrong on that last part.
我刚才一直在跟随你的思路，直到最后一部分。你在最后一部分就是错了。
I-- I do a lot of reading on this. You find me your meteorologist guy, and I'll find you mine.
我……我在这方面做了很多阅读。你给我找你的气象学家，我给你找我的。
No, no, actually, you have to go look for the folks that you're looking for. Because it's basically like this. 98 doctors tell you to treat your son this way. Two say this other. It's not conservative to go with the two. You're talking about the two climatologists. You're not talking about the 98.
不，不，实际上，你必须去寻找你正在寻找的人。因为基本上就是这样。98位医生告诉你以这种方式治疗你的儿子。两位说另一种。去选择那两个并不是保守派的做法。你谈论的是那两位气候学家。你谈论的不是那98位。
No, no, no--
不，不，不——
I mean, those are the numbers.
我是说，这些就是数字。
In the end, Bob doesn't convince the host. But the conversation's civil. He hears him out. Seems like he might even think about it.
最终，鲍勃没有说服主持人。但对话是文明的。他听了他的观点。看起来他甚至可能会考虑一下。
Which for now, is the point. For the last year or so, Bob's been getting into conservative publications-- Forbes , the Washington Times . He's also been crisscrossing the country, going to DC and business schools, universities. Pretty much going anyplace in the US where he thinks he can get Republicans to listen to him.
而目前，这就是重点。在过去的一年左右，鲍勃一直出现在保守派出版物中——《福布斯》、《华盛顿时报》。他还一直在全国各地奔波，去DC和商学院、大学。几乎去任何他认为能让共和党人倾听他的美国地方。
If you look at the polling of Republicans on climate change, one of the first things you notice right away is this huge gap between how Republican citizens feel and how Republican politicians vote. A recent nonpartisan poll by Pew found that 44% of Republicans believe the climate's changing. Another by Gallup found that 40% of Republicans are actively worried about climate change.
如果你看一下关于共和党人对气候变化看法的民调，你会立刻注意到的第一件事就是共和党公民的感受与共和党政治家的投票之间的巨大差距。皮尤研究中心最近的一项无党派民调发现，44%的共和党人相信气候正在变化。另一项盖洛普民调发现，40%的共和党人积极担心气候变化。
With that in mind, consider a vote just a couple years ago on the House Energy and Commerce Committee. All 31 Republican members unanimously voted down symbolic language that would have simply acknowledged the climate's changing, and humans are contributing to it. That gap-- 40% of Republican voters worried about climate change versus 0% of that committee-- that's Inglis's target.
考虑到这一点，回想一下几年前在众议院能源与商业委员会进行的一次投票。所有31名共和党成员一致投票否决了一项象征性的语言，该语言本可以简单地承认气候正在变化，且人类正在为此做出贡献。那个差距——40%担心的共和党选民对阵委员会中0%的支持率——这就是英格利斯的攻击目标。
That's his business opportunity. That's what makes his mission seem realistic. It's like 40% of Republicans want ham sandwiches. Surely you can persuade a few more Republicans to sell ham sandwiches.
那是他的商业机会。那让他的使命看起来很现实。这就像40%的共和党人想要火腿三明治。你肯定能说服更多共和党人去卖火腿三明治。
Inglis's group has counted all the Republicans in the House and Senate who have ever publicly acknowledged that climate change is real. There's 20 names on their list, out of 278 Republicans. The hunch you start to get is that there must be Republicans who believe the science but are just afraid to stick their neck out for the issue.
英格利斯的组织统计了众议院和参议院中所有曾经公开承认气候变化是真实存在的共和党人。在278名共和党人中，名单上有20个名字。你开始产生的感觉是，一定有共和党人相信科学，但只是害怕在这个问题上挺身而出。
Do you know, personally, Republican members who find the science credible but would never say so publicly?
你个人认识认为科学是可信的但永远不会公开表达的共和党议员吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Can you name them?
你能点名吗？
No, I'd better not do that. [LAUGHTER] I can't out 'em. But so yeah, there are members of Congress, Republicans, who know better, but they're afraid of crossing what's become the orthodoxy. This winter, I was visiting the gym, the House gym in Washington, a couple months ago. And a friend, a member of Congress, and I were talking, and--
不，我最好不要那样做。[笑声] 我不能暴露他们。所以是的，有国会议员，共和党人，他们心知肚明，但他们害怕违背已经成为正统的观点。这个冬天，我去了健身房，华盛顿的众议院健身房，几个月前。一位朋友，一位国会议员，我们正在聊天，然后——
This is a Republican member?
这是一位共和党议员？
Republican member of Congress. We were talking, and we had some discussion about what's going on Congress. And then he asked me at the end, now, what are you doing again? And so I told him, you know, I'm doing this thing of trying to convince conservatives there's a conservative answer to energy and climate.
共和党国会议员。我们正在聊天，讨论国会正在发生的事情。然后他在最后问我，现在，你又在做什么来着？所以我告诉他，你知道，我正在做这件事，试图说服保守派有一个关于能源和气候的保守答案。
Bob says at that moment, the Republican congressman he was talking to paused. Then he looked back over one shoulder, and then over the other. And then he turned back to Bob.
鲍勃说那一刻，和他交谈的共和党国会议员停顿了一下。然后他向一只肩膀后看了一眼，又向另一只看了一眼。然后他转回鲍勃。
He says to me, yeah, we got to get it right on that, don't we? And he sort of gave me a knowing nod and a wink, and just walked away.
他对我说，是的，我们得把那件事搞清楚，不是吗？他对我点头眨眼示意了一下，然后就走开了。
I talked to Republican staffers from both houses. Some said Bob's right, that more Republicans believe the science than will say so publicly. People are scared. I talked to one staffer in the House, an energy advisor to a very conservative Republican representative. He agreed to talk to me only if he was anonymous.
我采访了来自两院的共和党工作人员。有些人说鲍勃是对的，更多的共和党人相信科学，而不是公开表达出来。人们很害怕。我和众议院的一位工作人员谈过，他是某位非常保守的共和党代表的能源顾问。他同意只有在我匿名的情况下才与我交谈。
He told me Republican staffers tend to buy the science more than members, because they're younger. But he estimates there's at least a few dozen Republicans in the House who agree with the science but who would never say so. He also said something that Bob said, that if Republicans could vote their conscience on climate change, not have to worry about politics, you could pass climate change legislation today.
他告诉我，共和党工作人员往往比议员更相信科学，因为他们更年轻。但他估计众议院至少有几十名共和党人同意科学，但绝不会公开说出来。他还说了鲍勃说过的一件事，即如果共和党人可以在气候变化问题上根据自己的良知投票，而不必担心政治，你今天就能通过气候变化立法。
The very hypothetical math here is that if you got all the Democrats to agree on something, you'd only need 17 Republicans to get a majority in the House. But here's how far we are from that "Kumbaya" day. This House staffer told me that personally, he feels passionately about climate change. But he's never told his boss, because he thinks he'd get fired.
这里非常假设性的数学是，如果你让所有民主党人都同意某件事，你只需要17名共和党人就能在众议院获得多数。但这就是我们距离那种“天人合一”的日子有多远。这位众议院工作人员告诉我，他个人对气候变化充满热情。但他从来没告诉他的老板，因为他认为他会被解雇。
I said, fired? Do you really think you'd get fired? He told me, look, I'm a good employee. Maybe I'd get one strike.
我说，解雇？你真的认为你会因为这个被解雇吗？他告诉我，听着，我是个好员工。也许我会得到一次警告。
But if people in our district knew I believed in climate change, and I'm his energy advisor, they would freak out. I'd be a liability. If that got out, the smart thing for my boss to do would be to fire me.
但如果选区的人知道我相信气候变化，而我是他的能源顾问，他们会吓坏的。我会成为一种负担。如果传出去，我老板最聪明的做法就是开除我。
Inglis does have a small but growing list of allies. His group's website showcases some of this stuff. In general, it's people with solid conservative credentials but nothing to lose. Like there's this video of Ronald Reagan's Secretary of State, George Shultz, showing off his new ride.
英格利斯确实有一个规模虽小但不断增长的盟友名单。他组织网站上展示了一些这类东西。一般来说，这些人有稳固的保守派资历但没有失去什么。就像这里有一段罗纳德·里根的国务卿乔治·舒尔茨（George Shultz）炫耀他的新座驾的视频。
And I have my electric car, running on electricity from the sun. So I'm driving on sunshine. Take that, Ahmadinejad.
我有我的电动车，用太阳能发电行驶。所以我在阳光下驾驶。接招吧，内贾德。
Some other notable folks on the site-- a top economics advisor to Mitt Romney, two from the McCain campaign, Ronald Reagan's economics advisor, and conservative icon Art Laffer. But Inglis is the first to say, the thing he's trying to do, it's lonely. Like being in an ongoing, nonstop search for friends.
网站上还有其他一些著名人物——米特·罗姆尼（Mitt Romney）的顶级经济顾问，两位来自麦凯恩竞选团队的人，罗纳德·里根的经济顾问，以及保守派偶像阿特·拉弗（Art Laffer）。但英格利斯是第一个说，他正在做的事情很孤独的人。就像在进行一场持续不断的寻找朋友的搜索。
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
Greg Langworthy, glad to meet you.
格雷格·朗沃西（Greg Langworthy），很高兴见到你。
Bob Inglis. Craig?
鲍勃·英格利斯。克雷格？
Greg Langworthy.
格雷格·朗沃西。
Greg.
格雷格。
Recently I joined Inglis on a trip to the University of Kentucky.
最近我参加了英格利斯去肯塔基大学的一次旅行。
Oh, there is chicken available. That's why people are here.
哦，有鸡肉提供。这就是人们来这里的原因。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Watching him in person, what's totally apparently is just how hard he's trying. In just this one day that I'm following him around, Bob's schedule includes an appearance on conservative talk radio, a visit to a newspaper editorial board, several media interviews, a presentation at the University of Kentucky's law school in front of the UK Federalist Society, and then a big nighttime event with him and two other speakers. Bob and his staff said this Kentucky trip, this was the kind of event they really look forward to. A red state, a Southern state, a coal-producing state. This was the kind of place and the kind of audience that he's trying to reach.
亲眼看着他，显而易见的是他有多么努力。就在我跟随他的一天里，鲍勃的行程包括在保守派谈话电台上露面，访问报纸编辑部，多次媒体采访，在肯塔基大学法学院的联邦党人协会前做演讲，然后是他和另外两位演讲者参加的盛大夜间活动。鲍勃和他的团队说这次肯塔基之行，这是他们真正期待的那种活动。一个红色州，一个南部州，一个产煤州。这就是他试图到达的那种地方和那种听众。
Good evening, and welcome to the University of Kentucky.
晚上好，欢迎来到肯塔基大学。
The evening event's in the university's Grand Ballroom. It's this huge room. And there's a good-sized crowd, easily over 200 people. And the program, from start to finish, is custom-tailored to appeal to conservatives in pretty much every way you could possibly imagine. It starts with a respected climate scientist named Katharine Hayhoe, who also happens to be a devout Christian.
晚间活动在大学的大宴会厅举行。这是一个巨大的房间。人很多，轻松超过200人。而且这个项目，从头到尾，都是为吸引保守派量身定制的，以任何你能想象到的方式。它以一位名叫凯瑟琳·海霍（Katharine Hayhoe）的受人尊敬的气候科学家开始，她恰好也是一位虔诚的基督徒。
So science can give us a lot of facts. But in order to decide what to do with those facts, we have to look to our values. And my values come from my faith.
所以科学可以给我们提供很多事实。但为了决定如何处理这些事实，我们必须看向我们的价值观。而我的价值观来自我的信仰。
After her, there's a retired army general from Tennessee, a self-described conservative Republican who makes a case that climate change and fossil fuels, they're a national security risk. Bob is the closer, with a speech designed for climate skeptics. At the center of his speech is this pitch to do this thing that all kinds of economists, liberal and conservative, say would reduce greenhouse gases, and that's to tax carbon. Tax CO2 emissions. Bob clearly knows this isn't an easy sell to conservatives.
在她之后，有一位来自田纳西州的退役陆军将军，一位自称是保守派共和党人，他提出气候变化和化石燃料是国家安全风险的观点。鲍勃是最后一位，他的演讲是为了气候怀疑论者准备的。他演讲的中心是这种推销，去尝试做这种包括各种经济学家、自由派和保守派都说会减少温室气体排放的事情，那就是对碳征税。对二氧化碳排放征税。鲍勃清楚地知道这对保守派来说不是一个容易的推销。
Now there's a real problem with saying carbon tax. If you say it to a conservative audience, which is our target audience, conservatives break out in hives when you mention the word carbon, and they go into anaphylactic shock when you mention the word tax. And so you need EpiPens available to revive them, get them back breathing.
现在，说“碳税”有一个真正的问题。如果你对保守派听众说，那是我们的目标听众，当提到“碳”这个词时，保守派会起皮疹，当提到“税”这个词时，他们会进入过敏性休克。所以你需要准备好肾上腺素自动注射器来复苏他们，让他们恢复呼吸。
But hang with me now. After the second point, which is attaching a cost to carbon, comes a third point, which is, cut taxes somewhere else in equal amount. Dollar-for-dollar reduction in some other tax. So there's no growth of government.
但现在听我讲。第二点是给碳加上成本，然后是第三点，在其他地方以相等的量削减税收。以美元对美元的方式减少其他税收。所以政府没有扩张。
There's more to it, but that's the gist of it. Tax pollution, and then cut taxes on income. Bob says even if you're a conservative who doesn't believe the scientific evidence for climate change, that idea makes sense. You should still be able to get behind it.
还有很多内容，但这就是核心。对污染征税，然后削减所得税。鲍勃说即使你是一个不相信气候变化科学证据的保守派，那个想法也说得通。你仍然应该能够支持它。
The thing you want more of, tax that less. The thing you want less of, tax that instead. So cut income taxes. Tax pollution instead.
你想要更多的东西，少征那部分的税。你想要更少的东西，反而对它征税。所以削减所得税。反而对污染征税。
At all his Kentucky events, Bob says all kinds of things to remind conservatives, I'm one of you. He bashes unions. He calls Social Security a Ponzi scheme. Name-drops Milton Friedman. Talks about his Christianity.
在他所有的肯塔基活动中，鲍勃说了各种各样的话来提醒保守派，我是你们中的一员。他抨击工会。他称社会保障为庞氏骗局。提及米尔顿·弗里德曼（Milton Friedman）。谈论他的基督教信仰。
For over an hour, all three of the panelists hustle, like they know they're underdogs. Like they know the crowd's against them. Bob wraps it up at about 8 o'clock, the end of a 14-hour day for him.
一个多小时里，三位小组成员都在忙碌，就像他们知道自己处于下风一样。就像他们知道人群反对他们一样。鲍勃在8点左右结束了演讲，对他来说这是14小时工作日的终点。
Give me an amen. I'll stop preaching. Thank you very much.
给我一个“阿门”。我停止讲道。非常感谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
After all three speeches, they open it up for questions. And this is when things change. One student makes a comment to the general about how the US should get out of Afghanistan, and the room cheers.
三场演讲结束后，他们开放提问。这时事情发生了变化。一名学生对将军评论美国应该如何撤出阿富汗，房间里发出了欢呼声。
A few questions later, Bob's urging the Kentucky crowd to call their senators-- Rand Paul, Mitch McConnell-- to make the kind of pitch he's talking about, conservative to conservative. And the audience responds like those guys are some sort of joke.
几个问题后，鲍勃敦促肯塔基人群给他们的参议员——兰德·保罗（Rand Paul）、米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）——打电话，去进行他所谈论的那种保守派对保守派的推销。听众回应说那些家伙简直是个笑话。
Talk to Rand Paul.
和兰德·保罗谈谈。
[RAUCOUS LAUGHTER]
[嘈杂的笑声]
Let me tell you--
让我告诉你——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And at around this point, I was just, like, oh, this isn't a bunch of conservatives. This is a room full of liberals.
在这一点上，我当时心想，哦，这根本不是一群保守派。这是一屋子的自由派。
I followed Bob afterwards as he walked around, meeting people from the audience. He was visibly tired, but he kept a smile on his face, shaking hands and being friendly until the last person had left the room. It felt a little mean to point out that this wasn't the crowd he expected. So I said, instead--
鲍勃走动时我跟着他，见见观众。他明显很累，但他脸上保持着微笑，握手并表现友好，直到最后一个人离开房间。指出这不是他预期的那群人有点刻薄。所以我反而说——
So how do you feel like that went?
你觉得进行得怎么样？
Um, I wish we had a lot more conservatives. We're hearing mostly from left of center.
嗯，我希望有更多的保守派。我们听到的主要是中间偏左的声音。
Of course Bob knew. It wasn't the first time this had happened. Turns out to be a recurring problem for him.
当然鲍勃知道。这不是第一次发生这种事了。事实证明这是他经常遇到的一个问题。
Bob wants to have difficult conversations with conservatives about climate change. And he's doing that, for sure. But often he finds there's another audience out there, an audience eager to hear a conservative say, conservatives are wrong about climate change. They love it. And that audience, his natural fan base right now, a fan base he's not super interested in, is liberals.
鲍勃想和保守派进行关于气候变化的困难对话。他肯定在做这件事。但通常他发现外面有另一群听众，一群渴望听到保守派说“保守派在气候变化上错了”的听众。他们喜欢这样。而那群人，他现在自然的粉丝基础，一个他不太感兴趣的粉丝基础，是自由派。
Ben Calhoun. He's one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩。他是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three. "Find an Enemy." So now we move from the Republicans to the Democrats. I would argue that the guy on the Left who is doing more than anyone to reinvent the politics of climate change, to give our entire national conversation about it a good hard shove, is named Bill McKibben.
第三幕，“寻找敌人”。现在我们从共和党转向民主党。我认为左派中为了重塑气候变化的政治、给我们的整个国家对话以强力推动而做最多工作的人，名叫比尔·麦基本（Bill McKibben）。
Last summer, McKibben published an article in Rolling Stone Magazine that was basically a manifesto for how to do this. He notes that there is a weird science about the subject of climate change. It's back-burner. Over half of all Americans tell pollsters that they are worried about global warming, but that worry is not getting channeled toward any particular action to fix things.
去年夏天，麦基本在《滚石》杂志上发表了一篇文章，这基本上是一份如何做到这一点的宣言。他指出，关于气候变化的主题有一门奇怪的科学。它是次要的。超过半数的美国人告诉民调机构他们担心全球变暖，但这种担心并没有转化为解决问题的具体行动。
McKibben says the problem with the political strategy so far is that it's mostly asked people to do something that they feel very ambivalent about-- to go green. To produce less carbon dioxide personally. As he points out, we all like cheap airfares on airplanes that spew emissions.
麦基本说，到目前为止，政治战略的问题在于它主要要求人们做一些他们感到非常矛盾的事情——去“变绿”。在个人层面上减少二氧化碳的产生。正如他指出的那样，我们都喜欢在喷射排放物的飞机上买便宜机票。
He writes, quote, "Since all of us are in some way the beneficiaries of cheap fossil fuel, tackling climate change has been like trying to build a movement against yourself. It's as if the gay rights movement had to be constructed entirely from evangelical preachers or the abolition movement from slaveholders."
他写道：“由于我们所有人都在某种程度上是廉价化石燃料的受益者，应对气候变化就像是试图建立一场反对你自己的运动。这就像同性恋权利运动必须完全由福音派牧师组成，或者废奴运动必须由奴隶主组成一样。”
And he says, those of us who bite the bullet-- actually buy a hybrid car or those coil-y light bulbs that use less electricity--
他说，那些我们咬紧牙关的人——实际上购买混合动力汽车或那些耗电量更少的螺旋灯泡——
You can't help but look at your new light bulb and think, you know what? I don't think this is going to solve climate change. And you're right to think that.
你忍不住看着你的新灯泡心想，你知道吗？我不认为这能解决气候变化。你是对的，你会那样想。
You write in your article, "People perceive-- correctly-- that their individual actions will not make a decisive difference in the atmospheric concentration of CO2."
你在文章中写道：“人们感知到——正确地——他们的个人行动不会在大气中二氧化碳浓度上产生决定性的差异。”
Yeah. You can't make the math add up that way.
是的。你无法让数学得出那样的结果。
He says the other thing that should be clear to everybody at this point is that trying to explain the problem better-- sending scientists to Capitol Hill, making a strong case for action, trying to win over the doubters-- that has not been effective at getting legislative action. And he says it hasn't been effective because of political opposition. And he says the people who are pumping huge rivers of money into the opposition, funding studies to confuse the issue, and funding anti-climate change organizations, and especially funding politicians who do not budge, still, on climate change, are the oil and gas and coal companies-- whose products, of course, produce lots of CO2.
他说，此时此刻对每个人来说都应该清楚的另一件事是，试图更好地解释问题——派遣科学家去国会山，提出强有力的行动理由，试图赢得怀疑者——这在获取立法行动方面并不有效。他说它没有效果是因为政治阻力。他说那些向反对派注入巨额资金、资助混淆问题的研究、资助反气候变化组织、特别是资助在气候变化问题上仍然不动摇的政治家的人，是石油、天然气和煤炭公司——当然，它们的产品产生了大量的二氧化碳。
Their role is well documented and not a secret at all. Those industries fought to kill the 2009 cap and trade bill. They funded a multimillion-dollar lobbying effort that successfully kept the Senate from ratifying, or even voting on, the Kyoto Protocol, which was the first binding commitment on greenhouse gases in international law.
它们的作用是有据可查的，一点也不秘密。这些行业斗争是为了扼杀2009年的限额与交易法案。它们资助了一项数百万美元的游说努力，成功地阻止了参议院批准甚至投票表决《京都议定书》，这是国际法中第一个关于温室气体的约束性承诺。
But-- and this is what's new about McKibben's approach-- McKibben says that having an enemy like this is not a bad thing. He wrote in his manifesto that rapid political change requires a true political movement and, quote, "movements require enemies." As John F. Kennedy put it, he writes, "'The civil rights movement should thank God for Bull Connor. He's helped it as much as Abraham Lincoln.' Enemies," McKibben writes, "are what climate change has lacked."
但是——这就是麦基本方法的新颖之处——麦基本说有一个这样的敌人并不是坏事。他在宣言中写道，快速的政治变革需要一场真正的政治运动，且“运动需要敌人”。正如约翰·F·肯尼迪所说，“民权运动应该感谢上帝，感谢布尔·康纳（Bull Connor）。他帮助它就像亚伯拉罕·林肯一样。”麦基本写道，“气候变化所缺乏的正是敌人。”
And last fall, McKibben hit the road to sound the alarm that climate change in fact does have an enemy, and to organize an army against that enemy. His goal-- to turn the oil and gas and coal companies into pariahs, like cigarette companies, as a way to destroy their political clout.
去年秋天，麦基本出发敲响警钟，即气候变化实际上有一个敌人，并组织了一支军队来对抗那个敌人。他的目标——让石油、天然气和煤炭公司成为贱民，就像香烟公司一样，作为一种摧毁它们政治影响力的方式。
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Wow. Thank you all enormously.
哇。非常感谢大家。
Boulder, Colorado-- stop 21 on a 22-city tour. An 1,100-seat hall that, like usual on this tour, has loads of college students and, like usual, is sold out. McKibben himself is a 50-something with a runner's build and wire-rim glasses. On stage, he looks perennially like he is just about to get comfortable. He chops his arms up and down to punctuate his sentences.
科罗拉多州博尔德市——22个城市巡演的第21站。一个拥有1100个座位的礼堂，像这次巡演的往常一样，有很多大学生，而且像往常一样，票卖光了。麦基本本人是一位50多岁的人，有着长跑选手的身材和金属框架眼镜。在舞台上，他看起来永远像刚刚要让自己舒服一点。他上下挥动双臂来强调他的句子。
You can tell, from watching me, that I'm not really a trained orator or activist or something. This is not what I'm great at, OK? I'm a writer, which is almost the opposite. Um, um, um--
你可以看出来，看着我，我不是什么训练有素的演说家或活动家之类的人。这不是我擅长的，好吗？我是个作家，几乎是反过来的。嗯，嗯，嗯——
His road to the stage began in the 1980s. As a young reporter for The New Yorker Magazine , he wrote the first book for a general audience on global warming-- it was called The End of Nature -- and published a long excerpt in the magazine.
他走向舞台的道路始于20世纪80年代。作为《纽约客》杂志的一名年轻记者，他为大众写了第一本关于全球变暖的书——书名是《自然的终结》（The End of Nature）——并在这本杂志上发表了很长一段摘录。
When I was 27 and I wrote The End of Nature , my theory of change was people will read my book, and then they will change.
当我27岁写《自然的终结》时，我的变革理论是人们会读我的书，然后他们会改变。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which turns out not to be how it works.
结果发现那不是它运作的方式。
How it works, of course, is old-fashioned politics. Organizing people. And McKibben started to switch roles from reporter to activist in 2006, when he noticed that nobody else seemed to be doing this when it came to global warming. He says he set out on this current campaign after he saw some numbers that were sobering even for him, somebody who's followed this issue for decades. He tells his audience that everything they need to know about the climate issue just comes down to these few key numbers.
当然，它是如何运作的，是老式的政治。组织人们。2006年，当麦基本注意到当涉及到全球变暖时，似乎没有其他人这样做时，他开始从记者转向活动家。他说他在看到一些即使对他来说也令人清醒的数字后，开始了当前的运动，他几十年来一直关注这个问题。他告诉听众，他们需要知道的关于气候问题的一切就归结为这几个关键数字。
The first is two degrees Celsius. The world's governments agreed, in 2009 at the UN Climate Meeting in Copenhagen, that if the Earth's temperature rises two degrees more than it was before global warming kicked in, we're screwed. Just exactly how screwed, of course-- how quickly the ocean rise, how bad the hurricanes and droughts and food shortages-- that's all a guess. But two degrees is the red line that the world agreed on.
第一个是摄氏2度。世界各国政府在2009年的联合国哥本哈根气候会议上同意，如果地球温度比全球变暖开始前再升高2度，我们就完了。当然，到底有多完——海洋上升有多快，飓风、干旱和粮食短缺有多严重——那全是猜测。但2度是世界同意的红线。
Everybody signed it. The EU, Japan, Russia. Countries that make their living selling oil, the United Arab Emirates. The most conservative, reluctant, recalcitrant-- China signed. Even the United States signed on to this thing.
每个人都签署了。欧盟、日本、俄罗斯。靠卖石油为生的国家，阿拉伯联合酋长国。最保守、最勉强、最顽固的——中国签署了。甚至美国也签署了这个东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When you calculate exactly how much carbon dioxide it would take to drive up the planet's temperature two degrees-- and there's a famous and frequently cited 2009 study which does just this-- you learn that if the world keeps producing carbon dioxide at the rate we're going now, in just 14 years, we'll produce enough to send the planet up two degrees.
当你计算要把地球温度升高2度需要多少二氧化碳时——有一个著名的且经常被引用的2009年研究正是这样做的——你会了解到，如果世界继续以我们现在的方式产生二氧化碳，仅需14年，我们就将产生足够的量让地球升温2度。
Which is very bad news, of course.
当然，这真是坏消息。
And, McKibben says, even more frightening is when you look at all the coal and oil and gas that has already been discovered, that we know about and is sitting there right now, waiting to be pumped out and used, when you calculate how much carbon dioxide that stuff will release, it is five times more than the amount that would get us to two degrees. Five times more.
而且，麦基本说，更可怕的是当你看到所有已经发现的、我们知道且正坐在那里的、等着被开采和使用的煤炭、石油和天然气时，当你计算那些东西将释放出多少二氧化碳时，它比让我们达到2度的量多五倍。多五倍。
And this, says McKibben, is why the companies sitting on those reserves should be branded as pariahs. As an international global menace. Because they do, in fact, plan to pump that stuff out and sell it. In fact, the financial markets are counting on them to do that. Their stock price is based on turning those underground assets into revenue.
这就是麦基本所说的为什么应该给坐在那些储量上的公司贴上贱民的标签。作为一个国际全球威胁。因为它们实际上确实计划把那些东西开采出来卖掉。事实上，金融市场正指望着它们这样做。它们的股价是基于将这些地下资产转化为收入。
I mean, if they carry out their business plans, the planet tanks. Exxon alone, one company, has 7% of the carbon in its reserves necessary to take us past that red line. What these numbers show is that the fossil fuel industry is now a rogue industry, determined to do things that everybody who studies this knows are unwise, unsafe, crazy.
我是说，如果它们执行它们的商业计划，地球就完了。埃克森美孚（Exxon）这一家公司，就拥有储量中超过7%的碳，足以让我们越过那条红线。这些数字表明，化石燃料行业现在是一个流氓行业，决心做那些研究这个问题的每个人都知道是不明智、不安全、疯狂的事情。
At the end of every talk on his 22-city tour this fall, McKibben asked the students in the audience to rise to their feet and join a divestment campaign to get the colleges and universities to sell off their fossil fuel stock. It's a strategy modeled on the campaign against South Africa's apartheid government in the 1980s, which South African leaders have said was instrumental in helping push the regime into negotiations to end apartheid.
在他今年秋天的22城巡演的每场演讲结束时，麦基本都要求听众中的学生站起来，加入撤资运动，让高校卖掉它们的化石燃料股票。这是一种效仿20世纪80年代反对南非种族隔离政府运动的策略，南非领导人曾表示，该运动对帮助推动政权进行结束种族隔离的谈判起到了重要作用。
Look around at each other.
看看彼此。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
This is what movements look like.
这就是运动的样子。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
The idea that divesting of a company stock, particularly our stock, speaking as a long-time employee of ExxonMobil, to me that is not a very wise decision. We're a very good investment.
撤资公司股票的想法，特别是我们的股票，以埃克森美孚长期员工的身份说话，对我来说，那不是一个非常明智的决定。我们是一个非常好的投资。
When I called ExxonMobil, the world's largest oil company and the world's most profitable company of any kind, they seemed positively happy for a chance to comment about McKibben's campaign. The press office set me up with Ken Cohen, who's in charge of governmental and public affairs for ExxonMobil worldwide.
当我打电话给世界最大石油公司、也是各种类型中最赚钱的公司埃克森美孚时，它们似乎非常乐意有机会评论麦基笨的运动。新闻办公室为我安排了肯·科恩（Ken Cohen），他负责埃克森美孚全球的政府和公共事务。
Can I ask, when you read something like this Rolling Stone article, where he's trying to make the case that the oil companies should be treated like the cigarette companies, do you kind of roll your eyes and feel, like, seriously?
我能问一下，当你读到像这篇《滚石》文章时，他试图论证石油公司应该像香烟公司那样被对待，你会不会翻白眼觉得，比如，认真的吗？
That's a very good-- yes, that is how I feel. It is. It's trying to make a very complicated subject trivial. And to me, it's insulting, particularly in a university setting, to students and faculty. It is not getting at all at what the debate and discussion should be about.
这是一个非常好的——是的，那就是我的感受。是的。它试图让一个非常复杂的主题变得琐碎。对我来说，这是侮辱性的，特别是在大学环境中，对学生和教职员工。这根本没触及辩论和讨论应该关于什么的内容。
These days, it's important to note that ExxonMobil acknowledges that climate change is real, and that mankind's emissions have an impact. And this may surprise you-- since 2009, ExxonMobil has supported a carbon tax. The same type of carbon tax that McKibben calls for.
这些天，重要的一点是埃克森美孚承认气候变化是真实的，且人类的排放物有影响。这可能会让你感到惊讶——自2009年以来，埃克森美孚一直支持碳税。与麦基本呼吁的相同类型的碳税。
But Cohen says that McKibben oversimplifies when he acts like, oh, let's just switch from fossil fuels to something else, and we can do that in 14 years. He says that even if you make a heroic increase in the amount of electricity produced by wind and solar power, it won't be enough by then.
但科恩说，麦基本在表现得好像“哦，让我们从化石燃料切换到其他东西，我们可以在14年内做到”时过度简化了。他说，即使你让风能和太阳能产生的电力出现英雄式的增长，到那时也不够。
It is totally unrealistic to think that we would have substitutes for the current energy sources. They just do not exist.
认为我们会有现有能源的替代品是完全不现实的。它们根本不存在。
But when it comes to the numbers at the heart of McKibben's argument, the numbers showing that if Exxon and other companies simply sell what is in their reserves, they will drive up the planet's temperature far more than two degrees, I asked Cohen and his PR guy, and the press people at the oil industry lobbying group, the American Petroleum Institute, several times for anything they might have that would dispute those numbers. And they didn't come up with anything. Finally, Exxon sent me to an industry-funded expert at MIT who told me not only that McKibben's numbers were solid but that in fact, at current rate of emissions, by the end of the century, we'll probably raise the planet's temperature five degrees.
但当涉及到麦基本论点核心的数字时，即如果埃克森和其他公司简单地出售它们储量中的东西，它们将把地球温度提高到远超过2度的数字时，我多次询问科恩和他的公关人员，以及石油行业游说团体美国石油协会（American Petroleum Institute）的新闻界人士，有没有什么可以反驳这些数字的。他们什么也没拿出来。最后，埃克森把我介绍给了一位麻省理工学院（MIT）由行业资助的专家，他不仅告诉我麦基本的数字是稳固的，而且事实上，按照目前的排放率，到本世纪末，我们很可能会让地球温度升高5度。
So McKibben issued a call to war. How's it going? Well, even if the oil companies don't seem scared in the slightest just yet, in the six months since McKibben's tour, divestment campaigns have sprung up on over 300 campuses. Five small schools have divested.
所以麦基本发出了战争动员令。进行得怎么样？好吧，即使石油公司看起来一点也不害怕，在麦基本巡演后的六个月里，撤资运动已经在300多个校园里兴起。五所小型学校已经撤资。
This is remarkably quick, compared to the South Africa divestment movement. It took seven or eight years to organize and get schools to divest in those pre-internet days. But calling around to student organizers, I found that at most schools, they are still in the very early stages. Way too early to show any results. Maybe getting a few hundred signatures on a petition, or they've approached their administrations for the first time and asked them to divest, and been politely told no. Or not yet, which is a typical first step.
与南非撤资运动相比，这非常快。在互联网时代之前，组织和让学校撤资花费了七八年时间。但我给学生组织者打电话时发现，在大多数学校，它们仍处于非常早期的阶段。离显示任何结果还早得很。也许在请愿书上得到几百个签名，或者他们第一次接触了行政部门并要求撤资，被礼貌地拒绝了。或者“还没到时候”，这是典型的第一步。
I've met with John Maeda, the president, Bill Decatur, the finance VP.
我见过校长约翰·前田（John Maeda），财务副总裁比尔·迪凯特（Bill Decatur）。
Emma runs the student divestment campaign at RISD, the Rhode Island School of Design, where she's a senior. She's met, by the way, with a handful of other administrators and board members there. She says until she saw Bill McKibben speak this fall, she had never been politically active in anything.
艾玛（Emma）负责罗德岛设计学院（RISD）的学生撤资运动，她是一名大四学生。顺便说一下，她见过其他几位那里的行政人员和董事会成员。她说直到她今年秋天看到比尔·麦基本演讲，她从未积极参与任何政治活动。
If there ever was a school that you would think would divest quickly, it would be RISD. In March, when Emma raised the issue at a faculty meeting, the faculty didn't just vote for divestment, they were unanimous. This, after all, is a school of artists and designers. There's no economics department. Barely a conservative on campus, everybody told me.
如果你认为哪所学校会快速撤资，那一定是RISD。三月，当艾玛在教职员会议上提出这个问题时，教员们不仅投票支持撤资，而且是一致通过。毕竟，这是一所艺术和设计学院。没有经济系。每个人都告诉我，校园里几乎没有保守派。
And Emma's first meetings were promising. The administrators were saying--
艾玛的第一次会议是有希望的。行政人员说——
You know, this is really great to see this kind of activism on campus. The students should be more involved. So glad you're bringing this up. And you're right, this is an incredibly urgent issue, and we should look into this right now.
你知道，看到校园里有这种行动主义真是太棒了。学生应该更多地参与。很高兴你提出了这一点。而且你是对的，这是一个极其紧迫的问题，我们应该现在就研究一下。
Were you getting a little bit of, like, being patted on the head, like, oh, it's so good that you young people are being active and thinking about the issues?
你有没有感觉到有点被轻拍头的感觉，比如，哦，你们年轻人积极参与并思考这些问题真是太好了？
Yeah. Basically saying, you know, I was an activist in Divest in Apartheid. You know, I'm as liberal as they come. And so I left feeling over the moon. It was, this is going to be easier than I thought. We're going to divest within a month. [LAUGHS] And it's easy as that.
是的。基本上说，你知道，我在“撤资南非种族隔离”中是一名积极分子。你知道，我是自由派中最自由的。所以我离开时感觉飘飘然。它是，这比我想象的要容易。我们会在一个月内撤资。[笑声] 就这么简单。
And so I waited to hear back from them, and I waited and I waited. And I eventually heard back. They said well, we've looked into it, and it's going to be basically impossible to do.
所以我等着他们的回复，我等啊等。我最终听到了回复。他们说好吧，我们研究了一下，基本上不可能做到。
RISD officials declined to be interviewed for this story. But Emma says that their reason for saying no was this-- that RISD's $300 million endowment is managed by a firm that mixes it in with other universities' money. Emma said she was told there was no way to separate out the RISD money from the rest and just sell off RISD's fossil fuel stock. This kind of response is something that lots of kids are hearing around the country, that stocks can't be sold off for some technical reason, or that doing so might put the school's finances at risk. This was said to divestment activists in the '80s as well.
RISD官员拒绝接受本报道的采访。但艾玛说他们拒绝的原因是这样的——RISD的3亿美元捐赠基金是由一家公司管理的，该公司将其与其他大学的资金混在一起。艾玛说她被告知没有办法把RISD的钱和其他的钱分开，仅仅卖掉RISD的化石燃料股票。这种回应是全国各地的孩子们都在听到的，即股票不能因为某种技术原因而被卖掉，或者这样做可能会使学校的财务处于风险之中。这在80年代也对撤资活动家这样说。
Emma went to New York City and met directly with the firm that tells RISD how to invest its money, a firm called Summit Rock. She says she was told, basically, RISD is the client. If RISD wants to divest, they'd do it. Summit Rock declined to comment for this story.
艾玛去了纽约市，直接见了那家告诉RISD如何投资资金的公司，一家名为Summit Rock的公司。她说她基本上被告知，RISD是客户。如果RISD想撤资，他们会做的。Summit Rock拒绝就本报道置评。
As for the financial risk, in RISD's case, fossil fuel companies are just a tiny part of their portfolio, which organizers around the country say is not unusual at schools. Emma was told it was just $9 million of the $300 million. Which means that even if RISD loses a little money by switching to other investments-- makes, for example, 1% less per year off the investment than they do now-- their total loss will be--
至于财务风险，就RISD的情况而言，化石燃料公司只是其投资组合的一小部分，全国各地的组织者说这在学校里并不罕见。艾玛被告知在3亿美元中只有900万美元。这意味着即使RISD通过切换到其他投资损失了一点钱——例如，投资收益每年减少1%——他们的总损失将是——
$90,000. Which is the equivalent of two years of my tuition.
9万美元。这相当于我两年的学费。
And so with low financial risk at a school full of liberals, with former divestment activists in a number of key decision-making spots, at a school that prides itself on being iconoclastic and an innovator-- even here, in a situation that seems like it could not be friendlier, Emma still could not get traction.
所以，在一所充满自由派的学校，在一些关键决策职位上有前撤资活动家，在一所以标新立异和创新者为荣的学校——即使在这里，在看起来再友好不过的情况下，艾玛仍然无法取得进展。
What this says about McKibben's movement is that it will take time to percolate. And one of the big obstacles I haven't even mentioned yet is student apathy. Yes, there are a handful of campuses with super-motivated, super-political kids who love being politically active. But many schools are like RISD, where it's hard to get most of the students very worked up about divesting from fossil fuels. Only half the students at the school where Bill McKibben teaches, Middlebury College, wanted divestment in a big student survey.
这说明麦基本的运动还需要时间才能渗透。我还没提到的一个大障碍是学生的冷漠。是的，有一些校园有超级积极、超级政治的孩子，他们喜欢参与政治。但许多学校就像RISD，很难让大多数学生对从化石燃料中撤资感到非常激动。在比尔·麦基本任教的明德学院（Middlebury College）的大学生大调查中，只有半数的学生想要撤资。
What happened next as RISD was a weird turn of events that is probably not typical of what is happening around the country. Emma says that one of the people who runs the school, a high-level person who would be in on any divestment discussions, told her, if you want us to say yes, you have to make us.
RISD接下来发生的是一系列奇怪的事件，这可能不是全国正在发生事情的典型例子。艾玛说管理学校的人之一，任何撤资讨论中都会有的高层人士告诉她，如果你想让我们答应，你必须逼我们。
Make us pay attention to you. Rock the boat.
逼我们注意你们。掀起风浪。
What did that mean?
那是什么意思？
That I needed to amp things up. Why am I so afraid of pissing people off? Why am I so afraid of causing trouble? You need to cause trouble.
我需要加大力度。为什么我这么害怕惹恼别人？为什么我这么害怕惹麻烦？你需要惹麻烦。
You need to make us pay attention to you. You need to make us talk about divestment. You need to make us divest.
你需要让我们注意你。你需要让我们谈论撤资。你需要让我们撤资。
So she made a plan to make everybody pay attention-- the board, her fellow students. They would occupy the university president's office. They arrived there first thing on a Monday morning.
所以她制定了一个计划让每个人都注意——董事会，她的同学们。他们会在周一早上第一件事占领校长办公室。
Hi.
嗨。
Oh, hi.
哦，嗨。
Is John Maeda here?
约翰·前田在吗？
He's not.
他不在。
With the president not there, Emma reads the statement that they had prepared to the president's assistant, Marina Mihalakis, who crosses her arms and waits patiently for it to end.
校长不在，艾玛向校长的助理玛丽娜·米哈拉基斯（Marina Mihalakis）宣读了他们准备的声明，后者交叉双臂耐心等待结束。
We will stay until President John Maeda and Board Chair Michael Spalter commit to presenting the case for divestment at the board of trustees meeting in May.
我们将一直留在这里，直到校长约翰·前田和董事会主席迈克尔·斯帕尔特（Michael Spalter）承诺在五月的董事会会议上提出撤资提案。
Thank you. Oh, stay-- you mean you're going to sit in my office?
谢谢。哦，留在这里——你是说你要坐在我的办公室里？
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
OK. Hi, Matel.
好的。嗨，马特尔。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm fine. I have a lot of work to do. I hope you don't mind if I just continue working.
我很好。我有很多工作要做。希望你不介意我继续工作。
OK.
好的。
Please go ahead and work.
请继续工作。
This is nothing if not a remarkably polite, respectful, and well-mannered sit-in. 11 students plop themselves around the edges of the room and try not to make much noise, so that normal business can continue in the office. RISD's president doesn't show up until the next day, so they sleep there that night.
这是一个非常礼貌、尊重和举止得体的静坐。11名学生围在房间边缘，尽量不制造太大噪音，以便办公室里的正常业务可以继续。RISD的校长直到第二天都没出现，所以他们那天晚上睡在那里。
The next day, the school gives Emma what she wanted. They agreed to put divestment on the agenda of the next board meeting. On the phone telling me this, she was thrilled. She declared victory. But there was another victory, just as important, that happened outside the administration building while Emma an the others were upstairs.
第二天，学校给了艾玛她想要的。他们同意把撤资列入下次董事会会议的议程。在电话里告诉我这个时，她很激动。她宣布胜利。但还有另一场胜利，同样重要，当艾玛和其他人在楼上时，发生在行政大楼外面。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
It was easily 150 kids, and maybe a lot more. Color-coordinated banners that Emma's team had made were hanging from most of the school's big buildings-- it's art school, after all. People came out of their studios to see what was going on. And suddenly, climate change was the thing that everybody was talking about. Which is the other part of McKibben's plan-- to get everybody talking.
轻松有150个孩子，也许更多。艾玛的团队制作的颜色协调的横幅悬挂在学校大多数大楼上——毕竟是艺术学院。人们走出工作室看发生了什么。突然，气候变化成为了每个人都在谈论的事情。这就是麦基本计划的另一部分——让每个人都谈论。
There couldn't have ever been more than 2% or 3% of Americans who actually were physically involved in the civil rights movement, right? Marching, or sitting in, or whatever. But watching those who were, seeing it, was enough to change the mood of the country.
物理上参与民权运动的美国人绝不可能超过2%或3%，对吧？游行，或者静坐，或者其他什么。但观看那些参与者，看到它，就足以改变国家的情绪。
If McKibben's plan works, divestment is just a means to a greater end. To shift the politics of climate change by putting the issue on the front burner, by nudging people off the sidelines and into a political fight. For so long now, the climate debate in our country has been a tired standoff between believers and doubters. If nothing else, if McKibben's successful, the discussion will pop out of that rut, and soon, we will all be arguing with each other about whether or not the oil companies are going to destroy the world.
如果麦基本的计划奏效，撤资只是实现更大目的的一种手段。通过把问题放在前沿，通过把人们从旁观者推向政治斗争，来改变气候变化的政治。长期以来，我国的气候辩论一直是信徒和怀疑论者之间令人厌烦的僵局。至少，如果麦基本成功了，讨论将跳出那个老路，很快，我们将都会争论石油公司是否会毁灭世界。
If enough people get engaged with that fight, and the financial markets come to believe that Exxon will never be allowed to pump all the oil that it has found, it could drive Exxon's stock price down. But even if it doesn't, if enough people are yelling about all this, other things might become possible. A carbon tax, or any of the other proposals that would deal with climate change on more of an urgent, wartime footing.
如果有足够多的人参与那场斗争，金融市场开始相信埃克森将永远不被允许开采它所发现的所有石油，这可能会导致埃克森的股价下跌。但即使没有，如果有足够多的人在为此大喊大叫，其他事情也可能变得可行。碳税，或任何其他在更紧急、战时基础下处理气候变化的建议。
So I don't know, what do you guys think? Does it feel like there's not enough in the background to back up what Bill's saying?
所以我不知道，你们怎么看？感觉背景中没有足够的支持来支持比尔说的话吗？
There was a moment back in October when I visited McKibben and his team of organizers, before all this began, in Vermont. There were 14 of them, nearly all of them in their 20s, sitting around a big room, typing on laptops. And watching them, the thought occurred to me-- if they're right, and they pull this off, then this is a historic group. Right?
十月的一个时刻，当我在佛蒙特州拜访麦基本和他的组织者团队时，在这一切开始之前。有14个人，几乎全是20多岁，坐在一个大房间里，在笔记本电脑上打字。看着他们，我产生了一个想法——如果他们是对的，他们成功了，那这是一个具有历史意义的团队。对吧？
These are Freedom Riders. They're the early suffragettes. Which, of course, is such a long shot, it's such a crazy long shot, they would have to go viral in a way that few things ever go viral. It's such a crazy thought that they could pull it off, even to them. They're the first to admit it.
这些是自由骑行者（Freedom Riders）。他们是早期的妇女参政运动者。当然，这是一个极其渺茫的机会，这是一个极其疯狂的机会，他们必须以极少事物会传播的方式传播。他们能成功是一个如此疯狂的想法，即使对他们来说。他们是第一个承认这一点的人。
But they're running at it. Hard. 'Cause they're not sure what else to do.
但他们在努力奔跑。因为他们不知道还能做什么。
Our program is produced today by Ben Calhoun and me, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Phia Bennin.
我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、美纪·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。菲亚·贝宁（Phia Bennin）提供制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Special thanks today to Richard Harris, Bob Massie, Eric Klinenberg and Adam Murphree at NYU, David Kestenbaum, Robert Krulwich, Michelle Harris, and Julie Beer.
塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。今天Damien Graef和Rob Geddes提供音乐帮助。特别感谢Richard Harris、Bob Massie、Eric Klinenberg和纽约大学的Adam Murphree、David Kestenbaum、Robert Krulwich、Michelle Harris和Julie Beer。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Julie Kumari Drapkin's reporting project, iSeeChange, is part of AIR's nationwide production, Localore, which is funded by The Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。朱莉娅·库马里·德拉普金的报道项目“iSeeChange”是AIR全国制作“Localore”的一部分，该项目由美国公共广播公司（The Corporation for Public Broadcasting）资助。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, it's weird. Every week after he hears our program, he finds me in the recording booth and says the same thing.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板Torey Malatia先生负责。你知道，这很奇怪。每周听到我们的节目后，他会在录音室找到我并说同样的话。
I oughta take that damned recorder and smash it to smithereens.
我应该把那个该死的录音机砸得粉碎。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "TOO HOT TO HANDLE" BY HEATWAVE]
[音乐 - Heatwave的“TOO HOT TO HANDLE”]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。